all right let's jump into the news man
we got this story from the hill Russia
suspends only remaining nuclear treaty
with U.S Russian President Vladimir
Putin declared Tuesday that Moscow was
suspending its participation in the new
start treaty the last remaining nuclear
arms control pact with the United States
sharply upping the anti-amid tensions
with Washington over the fighting in
Ukraine okay I just guys it's it's so
difficult I can't look if you're gonna
nuke just do it okay it's the waiting I
can't stand we've been sitting here for
a year with these guys going like oh
I'll nuke you I'm gonna I'm you don't do
don't you do it and then we keep doing
these shows where they're like oh boy oh
man they're threatening us and then
nothing happens yeah so I'm kidding I'm
okay with the waiting I'm okay yeah
it's not that I want anyone to be bombed
but I'm running out of ways to say amid
Rising tensions like as things continue
like I can't say it the same way a
hundred times and to that extent like I
like assumed the American public is also
exhausted it's been over a year at this
point we've hit the year mark
when are we going to see the other boot
drop like how long do we just stay in
the perpetual and they tricked us
they've got us being here being like
come on already yeah what are you doing
yeah you're a pro war now dude yeah
right no uh but the scary thing is that
we're desensitized to it this news comes
out and people just shrug at it like oh
because
it's it's what we were talking about the
other day you know nobody nobody uh sits
there watching the grass grow and then
eventually just goes whoa whoa the grass
got too long no you ignore it and then
one day you walk outside you go oh grass
is getting long better mow it and that's
what's happening with this
it's incrementally getting worse but not
enough to where anybody actively is
freaking out or people are shutting down
government like with protests or
anything like that they're ignoring it
and as long as they keep Slow Rolling it
the way they do it will just escalate to
that point it's not going to be one day
the air raid sirens go off and nuke
drops on Kiev and we're like wow I can't
believe it's happened by the time an
actual ICBM hits a city we're going to
be like oh another one it's going to be
incremental the point where people are
just like well that's War I mean look at
what's going on in Ukraine right now
that's been going on for a year with
with you know this the Air Raids the
missile strikes the the misfires hitting
Poland there's been so much War the
crazy thing to me is
50 years from now they will write about
the ukraine-russia conflict probably the
nato-russia conflict because it's going
to escalate we're in it right now and it
seems like
non-existent far away it's it's been so
gradual that we are not shocked that
there is a land war in Eastern Europe at
this point we're bored with it that's
the scary thing well and we're not even
talking about the Middle East at all
so which is not like there's nothing
going on there
there's a ton there's tons of stuff
going on but I think we just got this
slow boil to the point where everyone is
completely used to the bathwater right I
mean I remember writing about you know
the months leading up before Russia
invaded there's troops on the border
there's troops on the border there's
troops on the border Russia says it's
not a big deal Russia says it's just a
military exercise and then like they
talked to Biden and it just went on and
eventually you know it felt like a big
moment in time but then we continued on
we know there's conflict we know there's
there's mounting uh geopolitical tension
everywhere but to what end right if if
you are American if you're an American
going about your day-to-day life like
there isn't a major change it's not like
Russia has now also invaded Pol like
Poland it's they they're staying where
they're where they are and so therefore
it doesn't feel like an escalation when
we learn when you learn about War
retrospectively you're able to say you
know if even though things things happen
over three or four or five years you
learn about them in quick succession so
it feels faster I have two a friend out
in La who I'm not going to name his name
because it's what he said to me I feel
absolutely ridiculous we'll call him
bill for the sake of the argument he has
two kids they're like 10 and 7. and like
dude do you you want to send your kids
over there because if you really think
Ukraine is Ukraine get out Putin you're
willing to send him over there
you want to see his legs get blown off
by a mortar
what do you say I didn't ask I'm asking
you right now dude are you willing to
put your kids over there because that
that's the direction look come on man
you know this is the thing that's so
tiring these these these liberal types
who wave the flags of course they would
never send their own kids I don't think
you have a choice if you if you set this
ball in motion gravity takes over you
can't stop it listen these are people
who Gorge themselves on hojos and Ding
Dongs and then demand that you pay for
their health care and the worst part is
this is that's not even this guy this
guy's like legit but he's he's in it
he's in that liberal state of La like
willing to throw his children away
because of Joe Biden like Joe Biden told
him so I don't I don't get it man you
think that East Palestine Ohio is bad
imagine if that was intentionally done
to the city nine times a day to nine
different cities by by a foreign
government that you have no control to
stop
that's what that's the precipice and
imagine you have one time one time and
East Palestine happens to only five
thousand people
and the President says I will not go
there and then secretly travels to a
foreign country Halfway Around the World
to give half a billion dollars to we
could not get action on Flint we could
not get action on Newark and Pittsburgh
and it was the left being like yo fix
these things Joe Biden snaps his fingers
to hop on a plane and fly to Ukraine for
half a billion dollars for a country
nobody in most people can't even find on
a map I like Ukraine man I don't like I
don't like what Russia is doing I get it
there's conflict we talk all day and
night about Prisma the energy sector
Nordstrom all that stuff but it's just
really gut punching demoralization when
the president outright says I will not
visit East Palestine these people you
just got to understand about this train
train crash Benny Johnson you guys see
this video he went out and gave 20 grand
he found the 20 houses surrounding the
closest 20 houses surrounding the
disaster he gave me to him a thousand
bucks that's really great I do I'll I'll
do the hassanism of does it really have
to be some commentator to go and give
money to these poor people why can't Joe
Biden why can't the government do
anything to to help these people I pay
taxes I have no problem with the
government being like yeah portion of
those taxes are going to go to make sure
that the disaster is cleaned up cleaned
up because it's kind of like Hey we're
paying for something right no no no no
no no no no no not only will he not go
there he'll go and give your money away
to a foreign country for a war that we
don't know anything about or why it's
happening and they try and convince us
we got to stand with Ukraine for what
reason are we are we at war in Ukraine
for what reason I mean I know it's
energy conflict it's Nordstrom it's gas
prom it's the cutter turkey pipeline
it's uh it's NATO expansion it's U.S
Global Empire it's NATO expansion it's
western expansion for what reason do we
not provide even a tiny bit of relief to
the people of East Palestine yeah well
so Betty Johnson shout out twenty
thousand dollars that's and I I know
Benny would do more if he could he
probably was like what can we afford a
spare in this budget and so he breaks
down where the money comes from and so
that's it it's up to a a culture and
political commentator to try and give
money to some of these people can we can
we take that 500 million dollars to
Ukraine and even one percent of it to
the people who are starting this
disaster because here's what you gotta
understand about that they've lost
everything those houses are worth zero
dollars now no one is going to buy a
house contaminated with vinyl chloride
and you know whatever glycol garbage is
all over the place I think it's more
than just culture uh commentators the
Michael Reagan the head of the EPA was
supposed to go to a climate who's a
climate change tour in Africa with Idris
Elba and then on the 17th Trump
announced that he was going to go to
East Palestine on the 18th the EPA
announced that tour was canceled on the
19th uh Reagan it's like oh I'll be in
I'll be in Palestine this come East
Palestine this coming week and then he
announces oh we're going to hold Norfolk
Southern accountable for what they've
done we're going to make them pay for it
which I'm not saying it that company
shouldn't but this is the same federal
government that said that the people of
East Palestine didn't qualify for FEMA
relief right they didn't they they
weren't enough of a disaster to get
assistance but then when we have an
unrelenting especially conservative
leaning media that's like no we want to
talk about it we want you to go there we
want you to drink the water then
eventually the EPA is like yeah we've
got to hold that private company
accountable I'm not saying that's the
wrong step I'm just saying why were you
thinking about going to Africa to talk
about climate change when we have our
own disaster in our backyard this is
like I don't think that waiting for
someone to do it is gonna they're gonna
do it but there's a technology where you
can clean up oil spills with magnets
this is developed about a decade ago CNN
reports on it you type up cleanup oil
spill with magnet and it'll come up and
put iron iron into the water and then
the oil like coagulates around the iron
but that's not the matter there is oil
there's lots of stuff in it exactly but
if it's a start I mean it's it's a
suggestion that maybe we can do
something to clean this up
I mean Ian that's it's not that far from
your hometown so no it's like 70 miles
from my hometown oh yeah it's pretty
close
so maybe you need to go at some point
I'm sure you will maybe if you go home
and visit I thought I think you'd do a
visit dude I thought about going there
just to smell just to smell it to know
is this gonna kill people like Because
unless you go and then I was like I
don't want to be there I don't want to
hurt my lungs and I'm like what what
that is that's what Biden say did he
actually say I'm not going there or did
he just not say anything the bite it was
Kareem Jean-Pierre I'm pretty sure was
asked and he said he has no plans to
that's because he's too sickly to handle
the air no no there's just no plans I
don't know if it was Korean Jean-Pierre
but the administration answered that
they had no plans and then everyone got
really mad because Trump then announced
I will be going to visit it's remarkable
man Trump for all of the awful things
people have complained about actually
cares about this country and Joe Biden
is representing some kind of occupying
force that cares more about West Western
power expansion than the people who are
doing the hard work to make this place
exist
Donald Trump struck the perfect balance
in my opinion he cared about foreign
policy he was negotiating peace deals he
wanted NATO to pay their fair share he
wasn't ignoring foreign policy but he
also made sure that the support
structure the infrastructure of this
country its people were being taken care
of perfect of course not Joe Biden and
the Democrats completely reject and
ignore the support structure of this
country and what it represents the
people and then he decides to do a
surprise trip to smile I mean I'm just
it is is a degree of triggered that I am
to see Biden hugging zelenski and
smiling
and then watching Benny Johnson's video
where he's like here's the best I can do
a thousand dollars and I'm like half a
billion dollars to to Ukraine for what
reason
and then the worst thing is we've had
rail workers threatening to strike
complaining about the safety issues
warning something like this was going to
happen see we're seeing we see more
derailments all the time but this was a
massive disaster the media then lies
about it and says everything's fine the
AP if you think anything's wrong with
the air water you're a right-wing
conspiracy theorist you know you gotta
listen to these Railway workers man and
you got to look at these railroad uh the
rail tracks because they get Warped and
bent there's a video of it I mean they
are Beyond fathomably bent and warped
and the trains like bouncing yeah it's
not just like they get a little messed
up in oops it actually gets blown off
yeah we got to pull this up when you see
how start how how bad these rails can
get and you realize that if we don't
when they say we need to reinvest in our
infrastructure this is what they're
talking about is we need to pull these
up and re-lay really new age strong
material look at this
it
is there sound on this thing
yeah they're sad let's let's
so for those that are just listening
we're showing you completely mangled and
bent tracks is this even the us though
ndnw Railway Mommy and Western
seems like us yeah
and the people were so I I I this video
is going viral people were sharing it
uh this is from March 31st 2017 but they
were look at this it's in Michigan it
says in Michigan Napoleon Defiance and
Western railroad is the ndw look at this
so the train has to slow down like
drastically even to get over wow look
it's on it's at an angle but hey 100
billion dollars in Ukraine well they
really need it well what's the structure
of those uh deals with Ukraine like is
like what are we owed after the fact
it's not just a straight donation oh
like a Lend Lease yeah what oh right
right but there is black Rockets to come
in and divvy up the land that's what
they did the Americans in World War II
as they lent the British so much money
that they had them by the balls after
the war right and that's why America was
so powerful after the war let's say you
know so we share this is in the US
what'd it say Michigan well I see in the
chats when saying mommy is in Ohio so
this is the Michigan Southern and this
is a story full video uh Story full is
owned by Fox News
so uh operates between Woodburn Indiana
Napoleon Ohio compromises 58 miles of
track yeah so it's not too far to expect
that that's probably part of the issue
those are the conditions yeah and they
took they said it was mechanical failure
and that the axle that was keeping them
together Caught Fire And they're they're
taking it back to the national uh the
NBT safety board their their lab to
study and to see say what's going to
happen and I just personally feel like
we should have an independent
investigator like I don't trust the way
the federal government's handling this
and I know that's such an easy talking
point to say but you know if their
response is this is not really disaster
you guys don't you know qualify for
support from the federal government you
know the air is fine everything's good
how do we know that when they examine
the axle that apparently caught fire
they're going to you know they'll see
and be like it really was just a fluke
it was action or something like it it
feels like a waste of time to to let
them test it themselves I feel very
black pilled maybe Blackwell isn't the
right word because I think the the the
difficult thing with talking about
stories like this and seeing these two
stories and contrasting each other
100 billion dollars to Ukraine
surprise visit by Biden 500 million
dollars and Americans suffering with no
assistance I think what they offered
like five bucks these contracts were
given saying shut your mouth and you get
what you get
seeing these things and I'm just like
is it
is it black filled or is it just realism
when we say things like we we can't
assume this will get worse because that
would be being black pilled and I'm like
now is that just being naive
you know a lot of people say don't be
black pill and I can understand like if
the context is don't be demoralized
don't be you know um
like I don't know don't be demoralized
you know you got you gotta you gotta
pick it up you got to keep working but
what I see with stories like this is I
was saying in the intro to the show is
my priorities start I feel a shift in my
priorities you know is my priority now
to go and warn people something's coming
or is my priority now to recognize that
event right now at the beginning of 2023
is
that's a lightning strike that's that's
a that's a a what what's the what's the
right word Catalyst no no no it's like
uh yeah it's a shot heard around the
world kind of thing it it is it is that
lightning strike that massive explosion
sound where you realize something is
deeply wrong and it's not being fixed
now we can sit here and be like now now
everybody we're gonna get it next time
don't you worry and I'm kind of like
well I don't know maybe maybe these past
midterms was some attempt at riding the
ship but when you have a government
completely abandon a city on in the East
Coast with now uh we're looking at
potentially five million people affected
Downstream from this not to mention the
tens of millions downwind from it we're
downwind from it
and it's completely ignored you're told
to shut up the media tells you to shut
up half the voter base of the country
doesn't care
I'm kind of like I don't know if it's
black pilled you oh deed you OD'd on
culture War pills but but but it's not
even it's not even it's not even about
any of that it's take a logical
assessment of what just happened and
then figure out what your logical move
should be and it's probably at this
point like wow
no amount of voting for a politician
will change what just happened
now I'm not saying don't vote I'm quite
honestly like 2024 is going to be
substantial like very very important
it just means that it's probably going
to be very bad and that's something we
will need to accept and prepare for
then you know
vote for Trump I guess I don't know I
think the status is all right I'll take
either one at this point yeah but I'm
I'm I'm seeing this happen makes me
swing back towards Trump on this to be
fully honest yeah I mean oh the county
that this is in Trump won twice in a row
and he won it by more during 2020. I
think that this sets The Narrative for
2024 pretty clearly right I mean Biden
if you look back at the withdrawal from
Afghanistan right people already felt
like he didn't care about how he was
taking the troops out he just wanted to
be the president that took us out of
Afghanistan and it cost us and now we're
seeing again how can he or any Democrat
go on to say that we're the party of the
environment when they would rather send
money to Ukraine than to help a
potential disaster in their own country
I feel like I can't comment on Trump
versus Santa's very clearly yet but I
know it becomes clear that the Democrats
are not saying they're not putting their
money where their mouths are thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time